we all love a bad guy but even better
than that is a bad guy who's trying to
do good these are 15 movie characters
who didn't let their introductions as
villains Define them it's hard growing
up in the shadow of your more successful
brother just ask Loki who went to some
pretty extreme lengths to prove himself
like say destroying New York City but he
has a bit of a come to light moment
after losing his mother and starts
working with Thor and Thor Ragnarok I
still hate it it's Humanity I'm not for
me it's not Loki even sacrifices himself
to stop Thanos making him the first on
this list who was able to redeem himself
while giving up his life that Vader
spent a good portion of his life serving
the dark side of the force but in his
final moments he redeemed himself as a
proper Jedi he turned against Emperor
Palpatine in order to save his son
effectively ending the Empire when he
did good to save you
you're ready
his grandson kylo Ren sort of follows in
Anakin's footsteps shifting back and
forth between the dark side and the
light show me
and speaking of characters who are
morally conflicted it's hard to tell
where Snape's loyalties lie Harry Potter
and the Half-Blood Prince seems to
suggest that he was more than just your
average bully when he actually kills
Dumbledore
and appears to join the Death Eaters but
when Snape allows Harry into his
memories we find out that he's actually
been working as a double agent all along
motivated by his love for Harry's mother
[Music]
and while we're on the topic we're
hoping that you might be motivated by
your love for our channel to hit that
subscribe button and maybe give us a
like while you're down there meanwhile
our next entry proves that love isn't
always the healthy motivator it may seem
to be Harley Quinn's problem is a
classic one she dated the wrong clown
where do you live
yes
after she and the Joker break up we
could see that she's a lot more capable
of doing good without him saving
Cassandra Kane's life and teaming up
with the birds of prey to take down
black mask are we ready bad guys just
outside Harley still struggles to do the
right thing but she's a lot more
interested in doing good than harm which
makes her somewhat similar to a certain
shape-shifting mutant Mystique never
meant to be a villain she's trying to
protect the interest of mutant kind
although that often comes at the expense
of humans and puts her at odds with the
X-Men but over time we see her turn away
from Magneto's extremist views and more
towards Professor Xavier's hope for a
better future at the end of X-Men
apocalypse Mystique even joins the X-Men
becoming the leader of an entirely new
team you're not kids anymore
and that's students your X-Men you might
even call her captain of her own chip
sort of like our next villain turned
hero let's be real here Pirates are
rarely the good guys when we first meet
Barbosa he plays the role of the villain
perfectly by kidnapping Elizabeth and
marooning Jack but after being
resurrected he comes to serve as
something of a weird Uncle to Our Heroes
when his daughter is introduced in the
fifth film we see a softer side to him
than ever before who am I to you
treasure it's clear to see that the love
of a child can go a long way to
redeeming a villain Disney's animated
Sleeping Beauty had Maleficent curse
Aurora because she wasn't invited to a
party I really felt quite distressed
that not receiving an invitation the
live-action movie Dives a little deeper
having her curse Aurora to get revenge
against her cruel father but as
Maleficent watches Aurora grow she
eventually comes to love her and she's
even able to wake Aurora with true
love's kiss hello godmother when we
first meet Decker cha he was driven by a
need for revenge against Dominic Toretto
and his career over the defeat of his
brother where's now little brother wanna
sell you one last
but between his sharp wit and prior M16
training Deckard was just too good to
give up he later teamed up with our
heroes to take down Cipher and as of
Hobbs and Shaw he officially became a
hero but Deckard isn't the only one to
have done some crazy things for his
family nebula had it pretty rough
growing up being the adopted daughter of
an Intergalactic War board under his
orders she hunted down the Guardians of
the Galaxy but changed her tune upon
making amends with Gamora he will always
be my sister she teams up with the
Avengers to help them take down Thanos
and afterwards it becomes a member of
the Guardians of the Galaxy she is still
a little rough around the edges but
she's trying to move Beyond her past the
T800 is a literal killing machine he
served as a terrifying villain to the
first Terminator movie having been sent
back in time to hunt down Sarah Connor
but when Arnold Schwarzenegger made a
name for himself playing Heroes James
Cameron decided to play on this image
when it came time for him to write the
sequel revealing that t-800 had been
reprogrammed not to kill my mission is
to protect you
being Captain America's best friend
comes with consequences after Bucky was
taken by Hydra he was brainwashed into
becoming a terrifying human weapon known
as the Winter Soldier still Steve
refused to give up on him you're my
friend and upon remembering his life
before Hydra Steve Rogers best friend
was back now haunted by his prior
actions Bucky tries to do good alongside
the Avengers compared to brainwashed
hydra agents and curse happy fairies
being a showboating boxer doesn't
exactly make Apollo the most terrifying
villain here but he serves as the
antagonist of the first Rocky movie and
actively believes our hero in the sequel
it isn't until Rocky loses his trainer
that Apollo steps in to help him out
maybe we could win it back together and
the two actually form a pretty close
Bond over time Rocky even went on to
train Apollo's son Adonis in later Creed
movies what could be more Despicable
than taking advantage of Orphans grow
only adopted his girls to complete his
super villainous goal of stealing the
moon but over time time he comes to form
a genuine bond with him over the course
of sequels we can see how Gru Works to
reform his evil ways in order to become
a legitimate father Megamind became a
super villain mostly through
circumstance he and Metro man were both
aliens sent to Earth as babies but while
Metro man was raised by a loving family
megabind was raised in a prison this set
up a rivalry between the two of them
that came to its conclusion when
Megamind actually seemed to defeat
metroman which left Megamind board with
nobody left to challenge him but when
megaminds attempts to train up the next
superhero fails he's forced to step into
the role of the unlikely hero as the
literal clone of a guy named Dr Evil you
wouldn't expect mini me to turn out to
be the unsung hero of the third movie
although he originally worked with Dr
Evil I shall call him Mini-Me his
jealousy towards Scott and Goldmember
encouraged him to leave behind his
villainous ways he teams up with Austin
Powers and even becomes something of a
clone to him and said dressing up like
him through a good portion of the movie
which of these reform villains would you
have to say was your favorite and are
there any that you can think of that we
might have missed be sure to let us know
in the comment section down below